the earth isn't flat but the solar
system is
about 4.6 billion years ago the material
that makes up our solar system was in
the form of a nebula which is pretty
much a big cloud of gas and dust in
space gravity flattened this material
into a disc like this one and then
pulled everything towards the center
eventually the pressure became so great
that a star was formed the sun the
remaining dust and gas particles
collided with each other and eventually
formed larger objects like earth
together the sun and all the objects in
space that its gravity keeps in orbit
make up our solar system we call the
biggest objects that orbit the sun
planets
our solar system has eight of them
mercury venus earth mars jupiter saturn
uranus and neptune these eight planets
are divided by the asteroid belt
asteroids are rocks that orbit the sun
that are much smaller than planets and
they're made up of nickel and iron
and unlike the planets most asteroids
aren't round beyond neptune is the oort
cloud a space at the very edge of the
solar system that's filled with comets
which are like space snowballs that are
made up of ice and dust
sometimes comets enter the inner part of
our solar system and can even be seen
from earth with long tails of ionized
gases
one of the most famous comets is haley's
comet which only comes near earth every
75 years or so be on the lookout for it
in 2061
the four planets on the side of the
asteroid belt closer to the sun are
called the inner or terrestrial planets
the word terrestrial comes from the
latin word for earth terrestrial planets
have solid rocky surfaces thin
atmospheres few or no moons and no rings
the closest planet to the sun is called
mercury
it's the smallest planet in the solar
system and it doesn't have any moons
next there's venus it's the closest
planet to earth and like mercury it
doesn't have a moon venus shines bright
in the sky like a star it's about the
same size as earth but you wouldn't want
to live on it it's the hottest planet in
the solar system and its atmosphere
contains an unbreathable mixture of
carbon dioxide and sulfuric acid
next is our home planet earth
earth is the only planet known to have
life on it the last terrestrial planet
in our solar system is mars
mars has a very thin atmosphere of
carbon dioxide and it has two moons
we've sent robots called rovers to mars
in order to explore the planet's surface
the planets on the other side of the
asteroid belts are called the outer
planets and unlike the inner planets
they're not made out of rock instead
they're made out of gases and liquids
and they have many moons and rings and
they're much much colder and much much
bigger than the terrestrial planets for
instance the planet jupiter is so big
that it could fit about 1
300 earths inside of it we call jupiter
a gas giant because you guessed it it's
giant and made up of gas its atmosphere
is mostly made up of hydrogen and helium
it has more than 50 moons one of
jupiter's moons ganymede is bigger by
volume than the planet mercury is
jupiter spins really fast on its axis
this means that a day on jupiter is a
little less than 10 hours long
if you travel another 650 million
kilometers or so from jupiter you'd see
saturn another gas giant in 1610 galileo
galilei became the first person to see
saturn's rings because his telescope
wasn't strong enough he couldn't tell
what they were he thought it looked like
the planet had ears
even though saturn's rings look smooth
from a distance they're actually made
out of rocks and pieces of ice that
orbit the planet because of saturn's
gravitational pull
the next planet is called uranus it's
the sideways planet uranus has smaller
rings than saturn does and it's so far
away from the earth that we can only see
it with a telescope even farther away
from earth is the big and blue planet
neptune because neptune is so far away
from the sun it's really cold here the
average temperature of neptune is about
negative 214 degrees celsius
it's also the windiest planet in our
solar system with winds going at more
than 2 000 kilometers per hour
so if you ever visit bundle up the
planets don't all take the same amount
of time to orbit the sun for example it
takes jupiter 12 years to orbit the sun
just once
in the same amount of time mercury has
already orbited the sun nearly 50 times
and neptune hasn't even made it around
once although humans have visited the
moon we haven't built a rocket ship that
can allow us to visit our neighboring
planets yet we've been able to learn
more about our solar system by using
other kinds of technology humans have
built incredible telescopes that allow
us to see into our solar system and
beyond and we've sent probes to other
planets and captured stunning images
even with all this research scientists
are still learning new things about our
solar system and its place in the rest
of the universe so maybe one day you can
help solve some of the solar system's
great mysteries too